COVID-19 is spreading rapidly
throughout the world.
The US has reported
over 5,000 cases so far,
with many states practicing
social distancing
to limit the spread of the virus.
The Centers for Disease
Control and Prevention
say that COVID-19 is spread primarily
through person-to-person contact,
from something like a cough or a sneeze.
But even if you're not in direct contact
with someone who is contagious,
you might still come in
contact with the virus.
If someone coughs or
sneezes into their hands
or wipes their nose and
then touches a surface,
it could become contaminated.
The CDC says this type of transmission
"has not been documented."
But experts say contaminated surfaces
can still pose a risk.
New research from the
National Institutes of Health,
Princeton University,
and the University of
California, Los Angeles,
broke down how long the COVID-19 virus
can survive on different surfaces.
And while these results could be affected
by temperature, humidity,
UV light, and wind,
it's a reminder of how
easily the virus can spread.
Luckily, the virus isn't airborne.
But it can linger in droplets
on particles in the air.
The study found that viruses could last
up to three hours in droplets in the air.
Maintaining a distance of
six feet from other people
can help avoid particles spread
through a cough or a sneeze.
On copper surfaces, like a drawer handle,
the virus can last up to four hours.
While researchers found that the virus
can survive on cardboard
for up to 24 hours,
the CDC believes packages or mail
are unlikely to transmit the virus.
COVID-19 appears to last the longest
on plastic and stainless
steel, two to three days.
That's longer than the
flu can live on surfaces,
according to the CDC.
Nonporous surfaces seem to allow the virus
to survive longer.
That could include things like doorknobs,
bus and subway handrails,
light switches, desks, and keyboards.
We don't know how long the virus can live
on a phone or a phone case,
but researchers speculate
that because it's
a smooth, nonabsorbent surface,
it's possible that the survivability
would be similar to plastic.
There are several steps you can take
to reduce your risk of exposure.
Always avoid touching your
eyes, mouth, and face,
and wash your hands with soap and water
for at least 20 seconds.
If you're not able to wash your hands,
use hand sanitizer.
You should also routinely clean
commonly used surfaces,
like doorknobs and your phone,
with disinfecting wipes.
And avoid nonessential
travel to public places,
especially at peak times.